elle a suis dit que c'était fini car
pire que ça ce serait la mort quand il y
en a plus y en a encore fait la malle
[Musique]
gestes préventifs numéro 1 lusage des
housses anti punaises de lit alors les
housses anti punaises de lit qu'est ce
que c'est une barrière infranchissable
une barrière physique qui va
littéralement empêcher une infestation
niveau de votre matelas c'est très
important puisqu'on sait que les
punaises de lit sont systématiquement à
proximité du lieu de sommeil c'est leur
cachette voilà elles attendent que vous
puissiez que vous endormir pour pouvoir
venir vous piquez donc elles ont tout
intérêt à se mettre soi dans les
coutures de votre matelas ou également
en dessous du sommet au niveau des
lattes en bois
geste réflexe numéro 2 faites attention
s'il vous plaît lorsque vous procurer
des meubles d'occasion beaucoup meubles
j'entends meubles literie est également
en canapé ce qu'il faut faire si vous
voulez vous procurer des meubles
d'occasion je vous conseille de
d'observer de faire une observation très
minutieuse au niveau des fissures afin
de voir s'il ya présence de punaises de
lit directement ou alors par le biais de
leurs excréments ça fait notamment plein
de petites taches noires c'est un signe
que le meuble a été préalablement
infesté
geste réflexe numéro 3 limiter les
refuges potentiels c'est vraiment très
simple la punaise de lit est un insecte
qui se cachent constamment donc éviter
de lui créer des habitations tout
simplement éviter donc en dessous de
votre sommier éviter d'en passer des
choses une valise etc il ne faut
absolument il faut épurer le lieu afin
qu'il n'y ait pas de cachettes potentiel
également veiller aussi à limiter
l'accès aux plaintes on oublie trop
souvent mais les plaintes donc je vous
conseille de faire un petit joints de
silicone transparent vous allez voir ça
évite notamment aux punaises de lit de
pouvoir s'y cacher et également fait
très attention aux cadres photos que
vous accrocher à proximité de votre le
sommeil faut savoir que les punaises de
lit adorent s'y réfugier derrière
gestes préventifs numéro 4 laver le
linge à 60 degrés alors je dis le linge
c'est les vêtements les draps les
housses de couette et c'est pourquoi 60°
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que à partir
de cette température là ça détruit
absolument mais vraiment ou compass de
la punaise de lit adultes mais également
à tous les stades larvaires on a les
nymphes les larves également les autres
ça détruit absolument tout donc conseil
il avait votre l'âge à 60° également si
vous vous procurez des habits d'occasion
fait très attention systématiquement ces
machines à 60 degrés alors là je sais ce
que vous allez me dire vous allez dire
oui mais moi y'a du match je peux pas me
permettre de laver à 60 degrés jeudi
l'âge délicat pas de panique à défaut
d'une température très haute on va
utiliser une température très basse -10
degrés pendant trois jours au
congélateur ça suffit largement
geste-réflexe contre les punaises de lit
numéro 5 attention au retour de vacances
parce que c'est là que tout commence
concrètement ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que la punaise de lit se transporte elle
vous accompagne elle part d'un point a à
un point b voulait ramener directement
chez vous par le biais des valises alors
faites très attention dès le retour au
domicile systématiquement vous allez
ouvrir votre valise et vous aller
inspecter minutieusement les coutures la
fermeture éclair etc afin d'observer
s'il n'y a pas de punaises de lit les
vêtements qui sont à l'intérieur vous
les prenez machine 60 degrés ça doit
être un réflexe et si malgré tout malgré
si vous détectez la présence d'une
punaise de lit vous isolez
systématiquement immédiatement votre
valise vous la mettez dehors et là vous
allez faire un traitement insecticide
tout de suite ça va être un geste
préventif afin d'éviter une infestation
directement chez vous